so what are we you're just a
ufo conspiratorial expert
would you call yourself an expert i know
more than the regular guy i don't know
what point you become an expert at it
you know
it's most of it is uh conjecture yeah
yeah you know kind of an educated guess
hey is this real
well definitely you definitely dive way
deeper into it you have a lot more
knowledge of it than anybody else i know
which uh it looks super cool because
it's really interesting well it is it's
one of those hobbies you just kind of
get involved with and then also you find
yourself in a situation
like this when uh you know somebody
asked me a question about
brazil and hey what are the chances
there could be
a ufo that crashed there i started
brazil yeah yeah i mean
so thanks for coming on we've had you on
before this is your second time hey guys
thanks for having me back
yeah absolutely so uh what are we gonna
talk about today
well listen you know i've been always
interested in some of this aerial
phenomena we've seen and some of the
different events that take place and
kind of always had an interest over the
last i don't know 15 or 20 years
looking at all the stories you know we
talk about the moon landings being fake
or yes or jfk
and i'm always intrigued by the
believers and non-believers
it's irrelevant really whether i believe
in it one way or the other i was always
curious as to what the other person
thinks
how did the story get started so um
about two days ago i had a buddy call me
up and um
asked me about a crash of a ufo
in brazil and i chuckled that's kind of
funny dude
he's like no really man i got this video
i'll send to you
it's a it's an instagram and um it's
something that's taking place in brazil
but there's been a ufo crash there i'm
like well dude if there was a ufo crash
that's that's pretty big information
that's pretty big news yeah
i haven't heard a word about it i mean
nothing online so in the meantime he
sends me the information
um i view it on my phone and i look at
it i'm like well i mean it looks like a
good movie
yeah like it really looks like a good
movie dude i mean someone's done some
great work here
and in the meantime while i have this
conversation with uh
with a good buddy of mine i have another
friend of mine that calls me out of the
state department asking me the same
thing
and he's not he's not nobody within the
state department he's kind of a of a
secretary
but again we share the same common
interest in this aerial phenomena that
we see
and so he said he asked me the same
question about a crash in brazil
two days ago and i'm like no dude i
really haven't are you being serious
he's like i'm being dead serious man
something took place in brazil and we're
not sure and i said listen i have some
contacts there now just a real quick
back on my background
working in the special operations
community um
uh approved countries to work with at
the state of
that the state department allowed us to
work with um
came up on many of my radar and brazil
was one of them the state department
said you can do work with them so we did
training
and we work with other special
operations guys across the board on the
law enforcement side
through the brazilian police department
through their special ops teams called
gara and then they have a a unit this
even above that
that the nickname is bop b-o-p-e
and you can look them up on online and
if you put the brazilian police vote
it'll pull them up and give you a
wikipedia background on them but these
are strong groups these are these are
guys that are
they're fighters they are looking at
narco-terrorism
across the board a good group of guys
highly trained highly specialized so
when this event kind of broke out i
actually reached out to a friend of mine
that was with uh
the he's the chief of police and rio de
janeiro
okay so bope is stands for
i can't pronounce that battalio de
operaciones
policias especiales so it's military
police of rio de janeiro yeah correct we
will all have special talents and again
all
the state of rio has its own military
force um it's actually brazil and what
they do is they break it off and these
guys are all would
you know in this in the states here we
have civil rights there they have no
civil rights
um they can you know you're better off
not to give these guys a hard time is to
give an example the guys that moved here
from rio and they live here now in the
states
had to retire here because they weren't
safe any longer in brazil
one of the guys there his last year in
killed 11 people
in his neighborhood so his wife used to
vacuum the house with a gun on her hip
jesus so these guys were serious i mean
they really were the tip of the
tip of the spear when they retired they
had to get permission to come here now
they work for a
a group here that is kind of spook
oriented
um they're working with the saudis right
now on several different programs
and i've done like i've known these guys
for a long time
so when this question got asked about
this crash i said well listen
i can get an answer to this right now i
sent a message text message to the chief
in rio but i never got a reply back
so i went to a buddy of mine who runs
this group and i said hey
you guys see anything about a ufo crash
and he had me on speaker and he goes
well i don't know but
i got news for you uh i'm not going to
tell you the guy's name the other guy
was sitting in his office because he's
sitting in my office now and just heard
you say that
and i said so i i said listen i know it
sounds funny but have you guys heard of
this and he goes no
no we haven't heard of it at all and i
said can you do me a favor can you just
check it just ask a question that's all
i'm asking
these guys are in brazil that you're
talking to these guys are actually now
located here in the states they work
here now stateside they retired from
brazil
okay to the u.s and you know can you say
what department they were from
um they were i'll just say they were
with gara they were with gara
which is which is a special ops group
out of brazil okay
real and again law enforcement guys okay
really heavily trained
so i had when i started asking the
question about this crashed ufo
they i could hear them in the background
kind of laughing and snickling
everything was a big joke
yeah i said listen just do me a favor
just ask the question quit watching the
history channel
exactly exactly so uh sure enough about
45 minutes later i get a text message
from him and goes dude you're not going
to believe this
it is real and bope
has the place locked down and i said
we're at and he goes just outside of rio
they're not telling us a whole lot but
they definitely said it's a crashed
alien vehicle of some sort there's a
in the videos that we got there was
initially a hole that you could see
through the trees you couldn't see
anything behind the on the other side of
the hole
but he said you're not going to believe
the story that's going to come out of
this
and i'm like i can't believe what i'm
hearing now with regards to
uh the fact that you guys have a crash
there and no one
no one knows about so they're fully
convinced saying 100 this is a ufo crowd
100
100 100 percent gara these guys at gara
uh
the guys from gara this is actually
coming from bope this is coming from
both he couldn't get a direct answer
from gara
so he called the guys a boat okay told
him yeah not only do we know about it we
have a security perimeter and got this
place locked down right now
yeah there was some talk that some
americans had pulled up yet but
i think the amazing point of this whole
thing is that no one knows about it
and i don't know you know well it's not
any mainstream websites that i've found
i
i
googled it i looked all over reddit i
looked all over i mean most of the links
are on twitter
there's some stuff on reddit but for the
most part it's
really hard to find legitimate media
sources talking about it there's one
vice article there's one vice article i
found this one right here
ufo over maje brazil sparks social media
panic and conspiracies
it talks a lot about it and it talks
about how like brazil
is kind of like a mecca and like a hub
for these kind of
sightings and these ufo encounters and
listen for me again
i had never really known that i mean
spending time there
i did some work out there with some
friends of mine and never did we see
you know anything that was slightly
unusual listen who's looking for them
with these these kind of events
um you know then you've got there's
other shows on tv right now you've got
skinwalker ranch that's on right now
dealing in extraterrestrial lives and
they've in the meantime on this ranch
with these scientists
that are now running these tests on the
ground in the soil are finding all these
weird anomalies these real high
radar microwave energy
that are shooting way up they're
actually you know on the show showing
you these huge readings they actually
tried to drill
down on the property until they hit
something they couldn't drill through
anymore and they actually started
suffering like a mini
earthquake that was taking place so you
know
again around the world these colossal
events seem to be taking place we had
some
more places here in florida last week
that said
over by nasa where their legal base
launches by kennedy space center yeah
that they saw almost 100 different
vehicles
up they were really really high up into
the atmosphere they couldn't tell how
far up
but they were all lights and moving all
different directions
and everybody's scratching their head
trying to figure out what is that and i
i said listen
maybe you know the new satellites they
have now that the us is using and they
put up a i believe a rocket just a
couple of weeks ago
that we're going to let these small
cube-like
4x4 satellites up and i said hey listen
maybe it's them
and he's like well why would you let
them go in such a low orbit
try i said listen again not knowing
anything on the aerospace side of it
kind of again looking at that
the anomalies side of it and i said i'm
not sure but
there's got to be an answer to it
somewhere right that could be a
possibility
you know so we look at we look at uh
again the navy releasing
two different video clips of two
different navy officers
who uh picked up something on their
their uh gun sites on their new f-18
hornets
and uh what odd thing is that the navy
let them just come out and
post the story and talk about it this is
the stuff that the pentagon just
declassified right the three videos
that's exactly what it is yeah
and it's happened back in 2014 and again
listening to the pilots talk about this
um and because the first questions that
came out of the the guy that was
actually talking to one of the pilots
was well isn't this classified
information he said listen nobody's
debriefed me on anything and told me i
couldn't talk about this
and it's not so much about the ufos i
want to talk about it's about the safety
that really concerns me more so than
anything because he said that the day
that we had noticed these and the day
that i picked this one up on my gun site
he goes it looks like a saucer it's not
moving he goes the odd thing about it
was
we're using a thermal imager on our f-18
hornets
that sees heat so we're looking for a
jet engine a hot spot
he goes nowhere in this video on this
vehicle can we find a hotspot
actually what we do see is around the
vehicle
just around the perimeter of it a real
light area which indicates it's very
cold there
so again trying trying they can reverse
that right those imaging those images
the the imaging systems they have on
those jets they can
reverse it to where hot as white or hot
is black
right correct and the f-18 hornets right
now are the ones they're using right now
where hot as black
okay so it shows up better especially in
the evening hours twilight zone
when you're out running operations
i